des commerçants tourangeaux pris la main
dans le sac une soixantaine au total qui
n'ont pas respecté les règles sur
l'éclairage nocturne résultat d'un
contrôle mené par la ville ils auraient
pourtant dû éteindre la lumière à
l'extérieur entre 1h et 6h du matin ces
magasins doivent maintenant se mettre en
conformité sous peine d'amande Léa
Turquie
la nuit tombe et tous ses claires
normalement jusqu'à 1h du matin plus
tard sauf activité nocturnes les
enseignes et vitrines retombent dans la
pénombre une extinction des feux
contrôlée par la municipalité de Tours
et résultat de l'opération 64 commerces
du centre-ville mis en demeure dans le
contexte de crise actuelle il nous
paraissait très utile de de donner ce
signal de sobriété qui en fait ne
dérange personne et même devrait
arranger les commerçants dans le sens où
ça fait quand même une petite facture en
moins à payer il s'agit juste de faire
respecter la loi ce qui encore une fois
arrange tout le monde
conséquence d'un décret de décembre 2018
pour ces magasins du centre-ville
principaux concernés la rue Nationale et
l'avenue de Grammont et si la limitation
de l'éclairage n'est toujours pas
respectée lors du prochain contrôle les
commerces s'exposent à une amende de
1500 euros maximum un enjeu d'autant
plus important en période de sobriété
énergétique on peut plus permettre voilà
d'avoir des factures énergétiques
importants donc le fait d'éteindre les
lumières c'est très bien le fait d'avoir
cette sensibilité du client qui va dire
bah voilà des commerçants qui vont qui
respectent moi j'adhère cette visibilité
qu'on a dans le centre-ville n'est plus
indispensable maintenant d'ici quelques
semaines des contrôles sont aussi prévus
au nord et au sud de Tours et pour le
centre-ville d'autres opérations sont au
planning concernant les portes d'entrée
qui reste ouvertes toute la journée et
tout l'hiver